[Music]
there are a lot of hard questions in
life like would you take the red pill or
the blue pill and what exactly does your
answer say about you if you are our
first time viewer click the red
subscribe button and prepare to choose
between ten of the hardest choices ever
would you rather a always be ten minutes
late or be always 20 minutes early if
you choose a you don't mind being late
to events if you are a hopeful person
with a positive outlook on life you
think you can get more done in less time
so showing up late doesn't stress you
out if you choose B you're someone who
needs to be in control you plan ahead
and probably learned from an early age
people appreciate punctuality
would you rather a live alone for the
rest of your life or be live the rest of
your life surrounded by people who annoy
you if you choose a you might identify
yourself as an introverted person you're
more likely to sit back and observe
people that engage with somebody the
thought of going out and interacting
with others gives you anxiety if you
choose B you might identify as an
extrovert you live for social situations
even if it's around people who annoy you
as long as you aren't alone you're happy
you are more likely to be out on a
Saturday night than home alone reading a
book would you rather a have all the
world's knowledge or B be a world's best
athlete if you choose a you are someone
who doesn't care what people think you
value education and not pleasing others
are being popular if you choose B you
want to be viewed as strong and
well-liked you want to have admiration
for your hard work and don't mind the
spotlight would you rather a have an
easy job working for someone else or be
work for yourself but have a difficult
job if you choose a you are comfortable
living an easygoing life you are low
maintenance and easy to work with to you
quality of life means having low stress
if you choose B you're someone who likes
to be in control you don't care how
stressful something is you thrive when
you are in the driver's seat you are a
natural-born leader would you rather a
find your one true love
or B find a suitcase with five million
dollars if you chose a
they actually already have true love in
your life you're someone who is
optimistic and a hopeless romantic
if you choose be you don't mind being
alone if that means you can have
everything else you want people may
think you're selfish but you just love
yourself and there's nothing wrong with
that would you rather a always be held
in high regards by your parents or be
always be held in high regard by your
friends if you choose a you might be a
people pleaser from a young age you have
tried to please your parents and it may
have crossed over into adulthood you do
what is expected of you because you want
to be loved if you choose be you might
be a rebel you are independent and don't
worry much about what people think of
you would you rather a take a vow of
celibacy or B take a vow of silence if
you chose a you are someone who has a
healthy relationship with yourself and
others you don't feel the need to be
physical with somebody to feel important
if you chose B you're someone who uses
physical touch to communicate your
emotions you know that it isn't what
someone says it is what they do that
shows their true feelings would you
rather a know the uncomfortable truth of
the world or B believe a comforting lie
if you chose a you believe in bracing
the truth will only make you and the
world better once you know what the real
problem is you can find a real solution
for it if you chose B you may be someone
who doesn't like change you are happy
with the current state of affairs in
your life and any changes could bring
you anxiety would you rather a never be
able to leave your own country or B
never be able to fly in an airplane if
you chose a you might be a homebody you
don't feel the need to be far from home
and traveling can actually give you
anxiety you find traveling far away is
more trouble than it's worth if you
chose B you are someone who yearns for
adventure you are always up for a
challenge and being able to go to
faraway places means learning more about
the world and yourself would you rather
a be attractive but poor or B be filthy
rich but unattractive if you chose a you
are someone who puts value in outer
appearance you want people to pay
attention to you and you want to be
perceived as a nice
for the person if you chose B you are
someone who doesn't worry about pleasing
others you know that people will like
you regardless of your looks and if you
have money you have security comfort and
the time to do what you want what did
you learn about yourself react in the
comments section below and for more of
the hardest choices ever check out our
friends at the taco who make videos
about interesting topics about
everything from relationships to random
occurrences
[Music]